eleven years ago I put together the
perfect plan to break into a private
concert and this is that story so this
all starts the summer of my junior year
of college I had a job bartending it was
a regular gig at a local bar on Main
Street but every so often I would take
catering gigs for a little extra cash so
that summer this catering company got
this contract to cater these five
private concerts for this ritzy private
school out east the concerts were Tom
Petty Prince Dave Matthews Band's I
forget the fourth one but the fifth one
was Billy Joel to give you some context
here Long Island has been referred to as
the Joel bubble now obviously he has
fans everywhere but I was in the
epicenter and he's just as big as it
gets I'm just trying to get you as
excited as I was now because my main gig
was at the bar I couldn't just abandon
all of my shifts so I decided to choose
two of the concerts and I got Dave
Matthews Band and of course Billy Joel
now granted I would be working during
the shift but it was a free way to get
in and I had already decided I would be
working as little as possible now the
concerts were supposed to be on the
sports fields which is pretty intimate
considering the level of the people that
were performing fast-forward to two
weeks before the gig I get a phone call
the catering company had lost the
contract now look they were a good
catering group but I just don't think
that they were able to match the Ritz
and glamour that the school was going
for needless to say I was heartbroken
not only was I not gonna get to see
Billy Joel but now I was out two shifts
at work days later I decided I'm still
going to this concert I will devise a
plan to go and see Billy Joel anyone
that knows me it was pretty easy to say
that they weren't surprised that I would
be attempting to do this this is just
what Rob does now the tickets to this
concert were like 1500 bucks apiece and
I'll probably two-line their goal posts
with gold leaf or something did I
mention the high school had a helipad
clearly buying a ticket was out so I
decided to Google some of the other
premiere
Catering companies in the area now they
were like three or four companies that
the job could have got tuned if I could
find out which one actually got the
contract I figured I could get my way in
now I struck out on the first call they
hadn't heard of the gig so I knew it
wasn't them
now the second call I asked to speak to
my dad in the kitchen they transferred
me to the kitchen and I'm talking in
circles so that they don't really know
that I really don't know anybody at this
company after the pass of a phone that
get like one of the sous chefs on the
phone and I'm pretend being frustrated
like I'm being transferred all around I
can't get an answer I just need to know
what is the catering outfit for the
private school concerts okay so once I'm
in then what I'll still be dressed like
a caterer I would wear my white shirt
and my khakis and bring a spare pair of
jeans hidden inside of an empty
sparkling water box caterers are always
hurrying somewhere carrying a bunch of
random shoes so I'd look like a caterer
running around getting ready for the
event but in reality I have a change of
clothes okay I'm feeling good about this
my friends were having a big pool party
that night which I would be skipping but
if I succeeded I'd be able to go back to
that party and have plenty of people to
gloat to I'd be the [ __ ] man all
right so the day finally arrives it's
worth mentioning here that my parents
were completely aware of what I was
about to do you know like I said it's no
surprise so I'm leaving the house my
mom's like all kind of excited to see
Billy only thing my stepfather has to
say is where's the local police station
so we know where to come pick you up
okay so it was time it was time to start
on my way to the private airport I pick
up the box of sparkling water dump them
out of my trunk they're all rolling
around jeans inside ready to go I pull
up to the airfield I park cater is
everywhere I get in line I've got my box
of sparkling water waiting to get onto
the
shuttle just a 5-minute drive down the
road who gets the gate we pull in
through security I get out of the van
I'm not catching as much as an I
caterers everywhere blending perfectly I
was playing the part
this event was gianormous I mean no
expense spared
they had lugged in full-size portable
walk-in fridges giant fancy tents with
like glass bay windows they had flowers
and professional lighting absolutely
nuts Oh God wait a minute the concert
doesn't start until dusk I have three
hours to kill I needed to be fitting in
with the caterers chefs party planners
running around and concert goers all had
bracelets and this was only going to
work if I remained a caterer until dark
and then I would change and head out to
the stage no one would be able to see if
I had a wristband on or not it was gonna
be dark so I sat on a folding chair for
quite some time and moved my positions
here there I just looked like a caterer
that was on a break it felt like ages
but the Sun finally started to set I
jumped into a porta potty to change
before you judge me like you know that's
gross
one what was I supposed to do and two
you should have seen this thing it had
running water marble countertops must be
nice I emerge with a white button-down
shirt and a pair of jeans I would blend
in perfectly with the other 1% but I was
about like 10 to 15 years younger than
every other person there as soon as I
walk out onto the field I was
immediately offered food and drink I'm
like what I made my way to the stage
with a beer in my left hand and a
kick-ass steak sandwich in my right this
is going to be awesome now my pulse was
racing the Sun is said the stage lights
come up I was here I was in I was in the
perfect spot I had done it now if you
think this story's done the craziest
part is about to happen within minutes I
was able to budge my way through and now
I am standing right at the foot of the
stage six feet from Billy the next two
hours I had the time of my life
so like 45 minutes or so into the
concert I couldn't tell if I was just
fangirling out or if
I kept catching billy joel's I for a
minute I was like oh my god no he knows
he knows I'm not supposed to be here
it wasn't that's impossible the regular
set finishes he plays for a damn long
time actually it was time for some
encores
so he obviously finishes with piano man
it was 10:30 or so on a Saturday the
piano sounded like a carnival I smell
like a beer I was fully immersed song
ends the crowd goes nuts people are
screaming more more more I'm like just
play for three hours you greedy bastards
that the man go home
so Billy unholsters his harmonica he
stands up he comes to the edge of stage
like a foot in front of him staring up
at takes the harmonica he [ __ ] his arm
back like he's gonna go throw it into
the crowd but instead he bends down and
hands it to me this mission was
accomplished now I know some of you are
watching this and saying cool but this
is clearly fake and to that I say I
promise it's not fake see for yourself
[Music]